він нова програма beat bull вісь
обласну ногу за рахунок мінімізації
ви могло село завального світло нею
підготовкою вчинивши я до чого по передніх
редакції програми результати на навчання
були прописані у такий спосіб ще про
вершувалося динаміка про розуміння вже
ними з'явилася місця видно щебеню
розрізна знаючи до вищого володіючи і
перевіряю осінню аналізу ю.
тоо новий не програмі ви значи на кінсі
ви результат і кайма і буде досягнуто
на першому етапі на чині там розміщена
акценти
зірка неви хрезультате фн одязі з не
ще й про знака та реалізацію
компетентнісного підходу він і у чині
наприклад вже не першого, то іншого
класу знімають механічно заучують і
таблиці і до дування то уваги
століття видно в magic 10 і в ми ж у 20-му
а вид володи ти про якщо вільну новачку
удодова не це мабуть не числу може 10
то помер у 20
аналогічно в таблиці ми множимо
дуже й іншого класу не за ви
зазубривати це блядь їм та дружина обмиють
розумієш ти суд є арифметичним їдом
але дружина коли давання однакових чисел і
виходять чичевa видно вліво типи поза
результати таблиці вже знімають розумі
ти
особливі гості таблиці множення та
викуриш то це їх править злодії
звичайних результатів в іншому класі при
ви і значення результат множення вид і
може
above так ти маєш кореня суми кілька
хлібних числу обидва ви простого ти прапор
по передньому
обидва доступні результати обозів тосол
цієї переставні закон але женя above
дата сяду групу вами проте виходу
данків абада по слідах нова але ж не я
все це бути їм але дружина складаються в
іншому класі чим дуже і розум з
читером малої можливості
їх слід це ви означає і в них по і
поза закономірністю у 3 цьому класі ви
можуть і 2
здається вже знімають володи ти апчу якщо
вільну новачку від звичайного помножені
відсiл означає ще геть i по вийнеш рибку
і правильно засовувати це вийти багато
не
громадських для ілюстрації на слайді
подано спірит наше незнання ви хто
Діяльність їх результату в програмі
математики для 1 класу
у редакції 2011 року якоба чому вже ту-2
було закладу на ідею реалізації
компетентнісного підходу та зроблено
акценти на вміння дієти
а не видно вліво ти математичні
правила вимиє і чоловік вилізти листові
тайві квіткова вигляд ніж і незнання вих
ідеальних результатів
про програму першого класу 2011 по 2016
руки
Яка чому він новий ній програмі 2016
уроку ще більше зроблено акцент на
Діяльності їх результаті відпал
і про знак і результативну і часту
програми і ви значення обидва скронь їх
результатів і кіма півдні монстру вати всі
вже не
а й статну про знак вапняної долі
іншої програми люті барана не участь pn
випробувань на річчю потрібно розтягування
процесу навчання пивних катували
психологи ладу жують ще формування
математичних миль та навідник не можна
тут його ти у степових вартових межах
чоловік без ефективних у розтягуванні
процесу формування в мінто навіднику
частини там його програми реалізовано так
і піт хіт доз місцю на вч вони апу
класах краще першокласних і лише
дізнаємося особи і слідуванням, адже
увагою 600 метрів ста без переходу
через розряд виймають краще відразу мід і
суть низ порозрядного задання так і
уваги she saw a в іншому класі вже
не втискаюся в алавіти суспільстві
новачку
вгадування це ж увага she saw the
без переходу через розряд рахунок це блядь
множу не те вже не іншого класу мого
тобі створи ось і результати таблиць
немає she's all with 2 до 5 з ручним для
себе способом а результати таблиці
множення
чисть девіс за потребу можна подивитись
у таблицях а в третьому класі вже не
маюсь ми тілу і правої ноги творить і
результати табличного множення то за
100 суати їх товариствах і зази нову
вчителі в мід і довести поясні ти
провели свою відповідь на прикладі бенкет
основного закону до дування який з місця
багато математики в 1 класі
продемонструємо у як можна розстебнутий
процес його обпалювання за значимо шиви
міг би іона плани та програми
я за стуса смердючого закону про числа
дуже моя ви кону ось це та ваня
то ж не манять she's all major 10
основі просто багато закон віддавання
випадково процесів чиня мая включать і
певм
Адже етапність бутівка дізнаємося нині з
приставним законом до давання його
застосування суспільствах так і година
чині номер офіс 601 десятку пісня
нині вже не по суті арифметичну
ідеї до давання до темна пропана вати і
завдання на складу нею ревнощів при
прикро не точок відрі скіф зліва направо
і справа наліво членів чаю
приставного закон віддавання did та
позначає рахунку сноу висловили три дні і
тягнуться ми, а результат цим самим
далі мови на нижній учень постер
горіти на матеріалі складу чисел першого
десятка 1 година ви по своєму всі пари
чисел зі складу youth це число іди
ти бачать ще й пари віку видозмінюються
лиж і порядком шис-у
цеху яблуня на нас топ нам та етапі даємо
вжилися випитувати або пари таких
числа не повторюється краще на етапі
підготовки
вже не на бувають та зведу того я хочу
перестав цієї до данг це значення суми
на зміниться за такого падіння
початкового з місця c і ви знову
вже не смузі зруби ти сама стіна на етапі
дізнаємося нині з приставним законом
обдарування вершина тему
етапі тепер ви карстовий учида світло
дітей пропав ну я їм вигнуті знаємо і
завданням засмоктуванні приставного закону
віддавання по шульги та суспільстві її випад
коли давання більшої кількості до менше
там у прикладі таких випадки ще
звички не таблиць задання писав 25
не бувають і звіду застосування
приставного закон віддання випадково ще
задання до жердиної іншої та цирку
щасливець повний світ і грунтується на
бенкет основному законі про знижку в мішок
біснуть ці випадки перед батьків та давай
невеликого числа думаєш про таку
розставляння вчитель може за класний у
календарного планування крем того
за таку динаміку обпалювання врахували ми
переставала закону та давай я їм ожив і
звістку про tomizu ватою ви пшеничним це
блядь задання чухав інше п'ятірки і
більше у вас
народили тинда сліди new table наприклад у
лісу ваню за ніжність та значення суми
зради одна брехня та данків